Welcome to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This week we're going to tell you the story of a woman who ran an interesting psychological experiment on herself. We look at the science of compassion and why being kind to others can make a big difference to your own life. It's easy to say, yeah, I can't make a difference, but everyone can make a difference. I want to tell you the story about a woman named Kelly Gillespie. She's in her early 40s, lives in London, and a couple of years ago, she took a psychology
欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。本周我们将为您讲述一个女人对自己进行有趣心理学实验的故事。我们来探讨同理心的科学，以及为什么对他人善良会对你自己的生活产生重大影响。说起来容易，我改变不了什么，但每个人都能改变什么。我想给你讲一个名叫凯利·吉尔斯皮的女人的故事。她四十出头，住在伦敦，几年前她选修了一门心理学
class. The class was online, hosted by the education platform Coursera, and it was taught by Scott Plouse. He's a psychologist at Wesleyan University. And then my life changed after doing professor's thesis course. And now I'm studying to be a psychiatrist and counselor. Kelly learns several psychological concepts in the class. One is called the norm of reciprocity.
课程。这门课是在线课程，由教育平台Coursera主办，授课老师是斯科特·普劳斯。他是卫斯理大学的心理学家。听完教授的论文课程后，我的人生改变了。现在我正在学习成为一名精神病学家和辅导员。凯利在课上学到了几个心理学概念。其中一个是互惠规范。
If you're nice to someone or you open up to them, they are likely to do the same with you. She also learned about the power of empathy. When you put yourself and someone else's shoes, it profoundly changes the relationship that you same with you. She also learned about the power of empathy. When you put yourself and someone else's shoes, it profoundly changes the relationship that you have with them. Now lots of people learn about ideas and psychology, but Kelly did something unusual. She took what she had learned in the class and she applied it in her own life. As well, I also like books and novels, so I spend a lot of time at the British Library at King's
如果你对某人好或者向他们敞开心扉，他们也很有可能会这样对你。她还了解了同理心的力量。当你设身处地为他人着想时，它会深刻改变你与他们的关系。你对他们也是如此。她还了解了同理心的力量。当你设身处地为他人着想时，它会深刻改变你与他们的关系。现在很多人都在了解心理学的理念，但凯利做了一件不寻常的事。她把课堂上学到的知识应用到了自己的生活中。我也喜欢书籍和小说，所以我在大英图书馆度过了很多时间
Course. My husband works just on the corner from there. So every Friday afternoon, I would meet him out of work after I'd been at the British Library of the Researching. And I would finish about four o'clock. He would finish about six o'clock. I had a couple of hours to spend. Sometimes I'd go to the welcome, sometimes I'd just sit
课程。我丈夫就在那里的拐角处工作。所以每周五下午，我在大英图书馆做完研究后，都会去他下班的地方找他。我大约四点钟下班。他大约六点钟下班。我有几个小时可以打发。有时我会去欢迎中心，有时我只是坐着
and have a coffee and watch people walking by. And always the same young guy. And always smiling despite not having anywhere to live or not having a job or any money, but he was always so pleasant and it started off a simply me giving him what's their change I had. But it went on for a couple of months and I got to know him a little bit and know what had happened to make him leave home
喝杯咖啡，看着行人来来往往。总是有同一个年轻小伙子。尽管居无定所、没有工作也没有钱，但他总是面带微笑，而且总是那么讨人喜欢。最初只是我把身上的零钱给他。但这持续了好几个月，我渐渐了解了他一点，知道了是什么让他离开家
and come to London. Kelly learned his name was Simon. She asked him if he would sit down with her for a cup of coffee. He was just walking past on the other side of the road. I think he walked up and down, taught them, got there a door, and on a night he would get onto the night buses because he had nowhere to sleep. He would just get on the night bus and travel down and down and down until six o'clock in the morning, hoping to sleep, hoping to not get attacked by the junks and the people that use the night buses in London. To make him feel comfortable, I told him a little bit about my life.
来到伦敦。凯利得知他的名字叫西蒙。她问他是否愿意和她坐下来喝杯咖啡。他当时正从马路对面走过。我想他来来回回走过，走到了一扇门前，晚上他会坐夜班公交车，因为他无处可睡。他只会坐上夜班公交车，一路往下坐，直到早上六点，希望能睡一会儿，希望不被伦敦夜班公交车上的瘾君子和那些人袭击。为了让他感到自在，我向他讲述了我的生活。
I told him I was waiting for a husband. I told him I was waiting for a husband I told him how long we'd been together, things like that. And I think by sharing a little bit of my life made him more confident to talk about his life. And I found out, I mean, he wasn't from far away from London, just in Kent on the southeast coast, so only, and now, with a away from London, way to go up. And what's going through your head about what you can say or do that would be helpful? He can't mention how much he missed his mum,
我告诉他我在等丈夫。我告诉他我在等丈夫，告诉他我们在一起多久了，诸如此类的事情。我想通过分享我的一点生活，让他更有底气去谈论他的生活。我发现，我的意思是，他离伦敦并不远，就在东南海岸的肯特郡，所以只有，现在，离伦敦很远，还有很长的路要走。你脑子里在想什么，可以说或做什么会有所帮助？他忍不住提到他有多想念他的妈妈，
how much he was so close to his mum. And that's a relationship that should never be damaged or taken apart. So I think that led to me asking him would he like to speak to his mum because my mum died ten years ago and if someone said to me now you can speak to your mum I would bite their hand off so I just asked him if he wanted to speak to his mum and he said yeah he never had a problem with his mum it was because of his father that he left home and he loved his mum very much and I just thought if he loved someone
他跟他妈妈有多亲近。这是一段永远不应该被破坏或拆散的关系。所以我想这促使我问他，他是否想跟他的妈妈说话，因为我妈妈十年前去世了，如果现在有人对我说你可以跟你的妈妈说话，我会毫不犹豫地答应，所以我只是问他是否想跟他的妈妈说话，他说他从来没有跟他妈妈有过问题，是因为他父亲，他才离家出走的，他非常爱他的妈妈，我只是觉得如果他爱一个人
so much he shouldn't be so distant from them. He has nothing to lose. Can you remember your home phone number of course everyone remembers their home phone number? You have nothing to lose, because you have nothing. So, let's just give it a go and see what happens. He didn't want to at first, he didn't want to speak to her, but eventually I found his mum and he said, um, hemphand assignments. She started crying immediately,
那么深，他就不应该离他们那么远。他没有什么可失去的。你还记得你家的电话号码吗？当然每个人都记得自己家的电话号码。你没有什么好失去的，因为你一无所有。所以，让我们试一试，看看会发生什么。一开始他不愿意，他不想跟她说话，但最终我找到了他的妈妈，他说，嗯，hemphand assignments。她立刻哭了起来，
because she hadn't heard from a woman for years. She didn't know whether he was alive or dead. And it was, if... Immediately, she was so emotional. And at that moment, I thought, okay, I'm just gonna pass the phone over and let them talk. They talked for about 10 minutes, 15 minutes. It was quite beautiful to watch because he started off not knowing what to say and being very guarded and defensive.
因为她已经好几年没有他的音讯了。她不知道他是死是活。那感觉就像是……立刻，她就非常情绪化。那一刻，我心想，好吧，我把电话递过去让他们聊吧。他们聊了大约10分钟、15分钟。看着这一幕真的很美，因为他一开始不知道该说些什么，显得非常防备和戒备。
That all broke down within five minutes. He didn't tell them that he was homeless. He didn't mention that at all. He just had been living in London. Everything's okay. I'm still alive. He never mentioned his situation at all though. And once the conversation was over, what did you say to him and how do things go from there?
这一切在五分钟内就瓦解了。他没有告诉他们自己无家可归。他根本没有提这件事。他只是在伦敦生活。一切都好。我还活着。不过他从未提及自己的处境。谈话结束后，你对他说什么了，事情接下来进展得怎么样？
I got a little bit bossy actually and I said okay, this isn't going to solve itself. So we went to Victoria Coach Station and I said if you don't do do this this is the best chance you're going to have of going back home. Seeing your mum and bought a maticot on the next bus to go back to south end and that's the last I saw him, he got on the bus and the way he went. In terms of what you've done with Zinc Simon, has it changed your behavior? Have you always been somebody who goes up to homeless people and helps them? Or have you actually become more proactive because you sort of say I realized that I actually can make a difference and maybe I can make a difference on a mass
其实我当时有点管闲事，我说，好吧，这不会自己解决的。于是我们去了维多利亚长途汽车站，我说，如果你不做这件事，这将是你回家的最好机会。去看望你的妈妈，买了一张下一班去滨海绍森德的车票，那是最后一次见到他，他上了车，就这样走了。关于你对西蒙做的事，它改变了你的行为吗？你一直都是那种会主动接近无家可归的人并帮助他们的人吗？还是你实际上变得更积极主动了，因为你觉得自己意识到自己其实可以有所作为，也许我可以在大规模上有所作为，
scale, but I certainly made a difference in one person's life and that teaches me that I could make difference in other people's lives too. Um, I think that doing the course with Professor Bliss most definitely opened my eyes to the reasons why people don't do something to help. I can remember he told us this wonderful story as part of the course, which was told originally by Kenyan and Vythermental activist called Wagarvi Mutamati. It's a story of a hummingbird in a forest that's been consumed by a wildfire and all the animals in the forest come out and they're transfixed as they watch the forest burning and they feel very overwhelmed and very powerless except this one little hummingbird that says
但我肯定在一个人的生活中发挥了作用，这教会了我也可以在其他人生活中发挥作用。嗯，我认为跟布利斯教授一起上课绝对开阔了我的眼界，让我明白了人们不采取行动去帮忙的原因。我记得他在课上给我们讲过一个精彩的故事，最初是由肯尼亚环保活动家旺加里·马塔伊讲述的。这是一个关于蜂鸟的故事，森林被野火吞噬，森林里的所有动物都跑出来，看着森林燃烧，感到非常震惊和无力，只有这只小蜂鸟说
I'm going to do something about this fire. And the vet's police told us this story about all the animals laughing at this little hummingbird. Does it flew backwards and forwards from the nearer stream? With one drop of water that are timed to put out the fire. But at least it was doing something and it was doing the best it can. And I think that's something that the baby... The baby hit a tuna with me. But it's easy to say, I can't make a difference, but everyone can make a difference.
我要对这场火做点什么。维斯警察给我们讲了这个故事，讲的是所有动物都在嘲笑这只小蜂鸟。当它在附近的溪流来回飞翔时。每次带一滴水试图扑灭大火。但至少它在做事，而且在尽自己所能。我想这也是那件……那件事深深触动了我。但说起来容易，我改变不了什么，但每个人都能改变什么。
Coming up next, the person whom Kelly says changed her life, her teacher, psychologist Scott Plouse of Wesleyan University. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. I first met Scott many years ago. He's a very smart guy, but the thing that leaps out when you meet him is that he's a really nice guy. Actually scratch that. Nice doesn't cut it. Scott radiates kindness. The class where Scott connected with Kelly was an online class. Believe it or not, more
接下来，凯利说改变了她一生的人，她的老师，卫斯理大学的心理学家斯科特·普劳斯。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。我多年前第一次见到斯科特。他是个非常聪明的人，但当你见到他时，最显眼的特点是他真的是个好人。其实算了吧。好人根本不够形容。斯科特浑身散发着善良。斯科特与凯利结缘的课程是一门在线课程。信不信由你，有超过
than 250,000 students from around the world signed up for the class. And at the end of it, Scott gave Kelly and his other students an assignment. It was called the day of compassion. Students had to spend one day being deliberately kind and generous toward others. Scott asked them to notice how these actions changed the way they felt about themselves. I asked Scott to tell me what students find when they do this. Students often report that it's transformative, that they're really surprised at the reaction, that people are so overwhelmingly report that it's transformative, that they're really surprised at the reaction, that people are so overwhelmingly positive that it starts to feed on itself. And by the end of the day, they report that this is a different side of me that I didn't recognize was there.
来自世界各地的25,000名学生报名了这门课程。在课程结束时，斯科特给凯利和其他学生布置了一项作业。这被称为同理心日。学生们必须花一天时间对他人表现出刻意的善良和慷慨。斯科特要求他们注意这些行动如何改变了他们对自己感受的看法。我请斯科特告诉我学生们在做这件事时发现了什么。学生们经常报告说这是变革性的，他们对反应感到非常惊讶，人们的反应是如此压倒性地……报告说这是变革性的，他们对反应感到非常惊讶，人们的反应是如此压倒性地积极，以至于开始形成良性循环。到了一天结束时，他们报告说，这是我没有意识到自己身上存在的另一面。
And is that because they are behaving differently, or other people are behaving differently? What's the cause? What's driving this change? Oftentimes it seems that compassion is contagious. We've talked about pain and forward, the idea that if you do something good for another person, that gives the other person a kind of lift, and then that person in turn will do something for somebody else, and it sets off a kind of chain reaction. So it's not just find the one dramatic thing that you can do in the day that can change the life of someone else.
这是因为他们的行为不同，还是其他人的行为不同？原因是什么？是什么在推动这种变化？通常情况下，同理心似乎是会传染的。我们讨论过将爱传递下去的想法，如果你为另一个人做了一件好事，这会给另一个人一种振奋，然后那个人反过来又会为其他人做点什么，从而引发一种连锁反应。所以，不仅要在一天中做出一件能改变别人生活的一件轰动的事。
You're actually asking people to change the way they live that day. That's right. And you know, Martin Luther King Jr. had a wonderful quote as well about the effect that you have, just in eating breakfast, the number of lives that you touch, where the cereal comes from, where the packaging comes from, who brought the cereal to you, where did the milk come from, and so on. And before you know it, you've touched thousands of lives without even realizing it.
你实际上是在要求人们改变那一天的生活方式。没错。你知道，马丁·路德·金也说过一句精彩的名言，关于你所产生的影响，仅仅是在吃早餐时，你接触到的生命数量，麦片来自哪里，包装来自哪里，是谁把麦片带给你的，牛奶来自哪里，等等。不知不觉中，你甚至没有意识到自己已经触及了成千上万的生命。
So, the students are asked to look deeply, to think deeply about their life choices, their behaviors, and to think about it specifically in terms of compassion. So, when you're eating your cereal, even if you know that these thousands of people have touched your cereal, how do you act compassionately to what all of them? Well, in some cases you might be thinking about people who are working under unfair labor conditions. You might be thinking, if I throw away this food, what else am I throwing away? You might think about when you drive to
所以，学生们被要求深入审视，深入思考他们的生活选择、他们的行为，并具体从同理心的角度去思考。所以，当你吃麦片的时候，即使你知道这成千上万的人接触过你的麦片，你如何对所有这些人表现出同理心呢？嗯，在某些情况下，你可能会想到在不公平劳动条件下工作的人。你可能会想，如果我扔掉这些食物，我还扔掉了什么？你可能会想到当你开车去
work, could you be bicycling, could you be walking, what consequences are there for other people? So there are many, many different connections that we normally don't have time to think about. And in this assignment, I ask students to simply slow down and think about those connections. You know, it's interesting when we actually start thinking about this in great detail, we often realize then that we are making choices that even though we think of ourselves as being good people, those choices are often unsupportable by the values that we claim to have.
上班时，你能骑自行车吗，你能走路吗，这对其他人有什么后果？所以有许许多多我们平时没有时间去思考的联系。在这项作业中，我要求学生们放慢脚步，思考这些联系。你知道，有趣的是，当我们开始非常详细地思考这一点时，我们常常意识到，尽管我们认为自己是好人，但我们的选择往往无法支持我们声称拥有的价值观。
You know, in my book, I talk about the idea that I was discussing the role that childhood vaccines play in saving children's lives in many parts of the world and how, you know, for $200, you could probably save a child's life in many parts of the world and how, you know, for $200, you could probably save a child's life in a poor country by making sure that she has access to just a suite of childhood vaccines. And when I gave my daughter a birthday party, this was a couple years ago, and the birthday party cost $200 or $250, I had a moment where I stopped and said, I'm spending $250 on my child's birthday party, and the same $250. I had a moment where I stopped and said, I'm spending $250 on my child's birthday party, and the same $250 could save the life of a child halfway around the world. Now,
你知道，在我的书中，我谈到了我当时正在讨论的观点，即儿童疫苗在世界许多地方拯救儿童生命方面发挥的作用，以及你知道的，只需200美元，你可能就能在世界许多地方拯救一个孩子的生命，只要确保她能够获得一套儿童疫苗，你可能就能在贫穷国家拯救一个孩子的生命。当我给女儿办生日派对时，这是几年前的事了，生日派对花了200美元或250美元，我有一刻停下来，我说，我花250美元给我孩子的生日派对，而同样的250美元。我有一刻停下来，我说，我花250美元给我孩子的生日派对，而同样的250美元可以拯救地球另一端一个孩子的生命。现在，
how is it possible that one child's birthday party could be more important than another child's life? And I felt like a terrible human being. Well, I'm sorry you feel terrible about that, but at least having a level of awareness, I think, can be a positive thing. The Princeton philosopher, Peter Singer, has a great example of this. He talks about somebody who's walking past some water and sees a child drowning. And this person happens to be in very fancy clothes, let's say an armani suit or some very expensive shoes. And the question is, if you're the only one there and the only one capable of saving the child
一个孩子的生日派对怎么可能比另一个孩子的生命更重要呢？我觉得自己是个糟糕的人。嗯，很抱歉你为此感到糟糕，但我认为，至少拥有一定程度的awareness可以是一件积极的事情。普林斯顿哲学家彼得·辛格对此有一个很好的例子。他谈到一个走过水边看到一个孩子溺水的人。这个人恰好穿着非常考究的衣服，比方说阿玛尼西装或非常昂贵的鞋子。问题是，如果你是那里唯一的人，也是唯一有能力拯救孩子的人
and there's no time to spare, should you in fact ruin your suit? Should you ruin your shoes and save the life? Let's say that you would lose $200 doing that. And almost everybody would say, of course, the child's life is worth more than the $200. And then Peter Singer turns around and says, well, what if we could demonstrate that there's a child's
而且时间紧迫，你事实上应该毁掉你的西装吗？你应该毁掉你的鞋子去救命吗？假设你这样做会损失200美元。几乎所有人都会说，当然，孩子的生命比200美元更有价值。然后彼得·辛格转过身来说，如果我们能证明有一个孩子的
life halfway around the world and that $200 would be sufficient to save that life? Why aren't you spending the $200? And of course, the question is lots of us don't, the child and the pond who's drowning feels visceral to us and feels like our responsibility in ways that the child halfway around the world does not feel like our responsibility. That's exactly right. There's an immediacy there. There's a vividness and there's different consequences.
生命在地球的另一端，200美元就足以挽救那个生命？你为什么不花这200美元？当然，问题在于我们许多人没有这样做，池塘里溺水的孩子让我们感同身受，感觉那是我们的责任，而地球另一端的孩子却没有让我们觉得是我们的责任。完全正确。有一种即时性。有一种生动性，也有不同的后果。
When you see somebody personally in need, rather than having somebody be abstract and remote and people will say to themselves, well, maybe that's true, but there are so many children in need. If I gave each one $200, I would be left in poverty. I can't possibly do that. And this is where psychology comes in. We tell ourselves stories about why it's okay not to help. Why it's okay not to help once. And we say, well, because if I then did once, I would have to do 100 and I couldn't possibly do that.
当你看到某人亲身处于困境时，而不是让某人变得抽象和遥远，人们会对自己说，好吧，也许这是真的，但有需要的儿童实在太多了。如果我每个人给200美元，我就会陷入贫困。我绝对做不到这一点。这就是心理学发挥作用的地方。我们给自己编造故事，解释为什么不帮忙是可以的。为什么偶尔不帮忙是可以的。我们说，嗯，因为如果我做了一次，我就必须做100次，而我根本做不到。
But in fact, sometimes you can do one, and one is better than zero. That's Social Psychologist Scott Plowes from Wesleyan University. When we return, we'll hear a poem from the writer Karen Ends, and we're going to issue a challenge of our own. I want to leave you today with a poem. It's by Canadian poet Karen Enz from her book Ordinary Hours. Karen came to write this poem after a moment when she experienced the
但事实上，有时候你可以做一次，一次总比零好。这是来自卫斯理大学的社会心理学家斯科特·普劳斯。当我们回来时，我们将听到作家卡伦·恩斯的一首诗，我们将发起我们自己的挑战。今天我想用一首诗来结束。这是加拿大诗人卡伦·恩斯的作品，选自她的诗集《寻常时光》。卡伦写这首诗是在她经历了一段
power of compassion, a small gesture from a stranger that lifted her heart. We asked her to read the poem and tell us about that moment. A goal will almost land. Go on. Everything is good. Up ahead a goal will almost land in front of you. Its wings will catch the current on a knife edge. Its flimsy element of bone will keep it motionless above the ground for just so long. And that pure pose will meet the light as if a god had ordered it to catch your eye. Go on. We are all defined by something like surrender, We are all defined by something like surrender, not a giving in exactly, not a yielding, but suspension. Perfect justice as the holding becomes opening as the moment of arrival on dry ground,
同理心的力量，陌生人的一个小举动温暖了她的心。我们请她朗读这首诗并讲述那个时刻。一只涉禽快要降落。继续。一切都好。前方一只涉禽快要降落在他面前。它的翅膀将在刀刃般的风中抓住气流。它脆弱的骨骼元素将使它悬停在地面上方恰到好处的时间。纯净的姿态将迎向光芒，仿佛上帝命令它吸引你的眼球。继续。我们都被某种类似于投降的东西所定义，我们都被某种类似于投降的东西所定义，不是严格意义上的屈服，不是退让，而是悬置。完美的正义，当坚守变成敞开，当到达干涸土地的那一刻，
small and blazing with intent becomes departure. with intent becomes departure. I think that most of us at some point in our lives, in dark times maybe, are looking for some kind of message from something, someone, some place. And that's where the starting point of this poem comes about. I was walking down the street a few years ago and a bus stopped at the stoplight and there was an elderly man who looked out the window at me and he nodded and in that nod in that gesture there was a kind of urging on. And I kept that image with me and I think that's what drove the beginning of the poem at least anyway, was his very kind look toward me.
微小而闪烁着意图，变成了离去。带着意图变成了离去。我认为我们大多数人在生命中的某个时刻，也许在黑暗时期，都在寻找来自某事、某人、某地的某种信息。这就是这首诗的起点。几年前我走在街上，一辆公共汽车在红绿灯处停下，有一位老人透过窗户看着我，他点了点头，在那点头中，在那手势中，有一种催促向前的意味。我把这个影像留在了心底，我想这就是这首诗开端的驱动力，无论如何，是他对我非常友善的目光。
And I took that as a message. That was Karen Enns talking about her poem, a gal will almost land from the collection ordinary hours. What would you do if you had to spend one day beaming compassion into the world? It could be something small, acknowledging a stranger. It could be something big, changing the direction of another person's life. Please try it and tell us what you found. We'll put some of the stories you share with us on the podcast.
我把那当作一个信息。那是卡伦·恩斯在谈论她的诗歌，选自诗集《寻常时光》的《一只涉禽快要降落》。如果你必须花一天时间向世界散发同理心，你会做什么？这可以是一件小事，向陌生人致意。这可以是一件大事，改变另一个人的生活轨迹。请尝试一下，并告诉我们你的发现。我们会把你们分享的一些故事放在播客上。
You can find us on Facebook at HiddenBrain or send us an email at hiddenbrainatnpr.org. This episode of the Hidden Brain Podcast was produced by Karam Agar Kalasan and Maggie Penman, special help from Jenna Weissberman, Megan Kane and Rachel Ward. I'm Shankar Vedanthan and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上通过HiddenBrain找到我们，或者发电子邮件到hiddenbrainatnpr.org。本期《隐藏的大脑》播客由卡拉姆·阿加尔·卡拉森和玛吉·佩曼制作，珍娜·维斯伯曼、梅根·凯恩和蕾切尔·沃德提供了特别帮助。我是香卡·维丹坦，这里是NPR。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。